heike zum heim wechseln
meine frage an dich wurdest du schon
noch von castingshows angeschrieben und
wenn ja was was du gedacht und wirst du
jemand besonders mitmachen
ich bin masse und ich will raus marcel
wenn man musik macht auf youtube wird
man regelmäßig von castingshows
angeschrieben
am penetranten ist auf jeden fall dsds
was habe ich mir gedacht ich hab mir
gedacht denen ich meine videos
weil ich mich ja schon mehrfach dazu
geäußert habe auch ich habe gedacht ist
auf jeden fall keine option für mich
aber ich wünsche auch allen die an sowas
teilnehmen auf jeden fall alles gute
damit fragt welcher deine auftritte
hatte ich bis jetzt am meisten
begeistert beziehungsweise welcher ist
hier am meisten in erinnerung geblieben
erst mal hallo mandy langjähriger fan
auf jeden fall
jeder auftritt ist besonders jeder
auftritt ist anders gerade in der
letzten zeit war aber natürlich der
auftritt auf dem video day vor über 8000
leuten der absolute hammer
und auch für jemanden wie mich der schon
seit jahren auf der bühne steht
gänsehaut adrenalin und aufregend hey
klicks um hi macs mein name ist pascal
meine frage wäre max was würdest du tun
wenn du einen plattenvertrag angeboten
bekommen würdest
ich rede jetzt nicht von irgend einen
kleinen label sagen im mai von einem
großen so universal music oder sony bmg
seine antwort dies genauso wie die
nachrichten von dsds und anderen
castingshows gibt es auch manchmal die
anfragen von labels ich bin ich ganz
zufrieden momentan für mich läuft und je
mehr du selber in der hand hast du bist
halt auch für den eigenen fehler
verantwortlich wenn mal ein label kommen
würde
was sagt junge war es kreativ alles in
der hand
und du kriegst die und die freiheiten
und das dann meinen vorstellungen
entsprechend wäre dann würde ich mir das
überlegen ich glaube aber um das ganze
ansatz zu beantworten im zeitalter des
internets sind die labels nicht mehr so
wichtig wie sie früher einmal waren
er möchte wissen warum sagst du
eigentlich am ende von deinen videos
immer bis spiderman vielleicht eine ganz
leichte sache ich habe früher mal lieber
gesagt bis später anstatt bis dann oder
schauer oder solche mühe später weil das
irgendwie näher klingt und dann könnt
ihr dieses wurst geht abnehmen und so
bis beide riesa bis späteren mann und
bis beide male und habe ich irgendwann
einmal gesagt ist bei der männer an die
leute alle gesagt du siehst ja auch ein
bisschen aus wiesbaden mit einer bbl
frisur und einer brille und so und dann
habe ich mir das irgendwie angewöhnt
amax und meine frage lautet wo nimmst du
die inspiration und deine texte zu
schreiben
gestern irgend bestimmten ort und kannst
dort gut schreiben oder wie tust du dich
inspirieren lassen und schreiben ich
schreibe auf jeden fall am liebsten zu
hause wenn ich meine ruhe habe also
meine ruhe ist mir sehr wichtig ich mag
das sogar noch nicht mal wenn ich dann
jemand mal anguckt wenn irgendjemand da
ist bei mir und dann musste er sich so
hinsetzen das nämlich nicht an begabte
auf jeden fall gerne meine ruhe
was mich inspiriert alles eigentlich
mein leben ich mache mir auch manchmal
notizen filme lieder vor allem situation
auf der straße wenn menschen irgendwo
mensch sind
das inspiriert mich ach so was auf jeden
fall wichtig ist oft konserviere ich
auch gedanken dann habe ich zum beispiel
irgendwann mal ein gefühl einen gedanken
und speichern wir den und irgendwann
kommt dann wieder hoch also wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel nicht schreiben was
sehr traurig ist kann es auch im moment
sein wo ich eigentlich sehr glücklich
bin
der magier 12 möchte wissen wie machst
du das die ganze zeit liebe und
nettigkeit und freundlichkeit in deinen
videos und solchen in dem du mitmachst
zu verbreiten nehme mal an dass das
nicht gespielt ist und daher auch die
frage woher kommt die ganze freude bis
beste einfach solchen kommentaren das
beste alter
also auch ein musikvideo ist ja im
endeffekt auch ein teil gestellt auch
ein musikvideo ist ja natürlich
schneidet man dann nicht sehen raus
indem man sie am besten gefällt
aber ich trage das nach außen was ich
mir am liebsten in der welt sehen würde
und das ist dann respektlos und
miteinander
und deswegen zeigt dass man ihnen also
max hallo christoph meine frage an dich
max werden ein mal ob du jetzt zu einem
fest möglich bei funk werden willst
sowie tools und joyce oder ob du jetzt
nur mal hin und wieder als gast dabei
sein willst und meine andere frage wäre
wie hast du vor zirka zwei jahren die
außenseiter kennengelernt und willst du
vielleicht irgendwann noch mal was
bedingung machen
leider kommen vielen dank für deine
video frage ja witzigerweise sind ja
blues und jazz jetzt gar nicht mehr im
festen cast von punkt dabei denen es ja
auch eigentlich so gar nicht gibt er
ständig wechselt ich bin jetzt gerade
dabei mal gucken wie lange die leute
bock haben wie lange ich bock habe ob
jetzt noch sechs monate oder sechs jahre
das entscheidet ihr und ich und
ja die frage mit den außenseitern wir
sind auf jeden fall noch cool
miteinander es war ja so die haben in
düsseldorf gelebt und ich wohne ja ein
neues und es waren drei kilometer
luftlinie
deswegen habe eine zeitlang sehr viel
gemacht die initiative kam auch immer
von dem der immer gesagt wir stellen zum
herz im takt vor und wollten dann einen
song für therapie haben den ich auch
gemacht habe ich auch sehr gerne gemacht
habe und ob noch was kommt oder nicht
wird die zeit zeigen von mir aus auf
jeden fall sehr gerne